all right a local businessman that says
he has achieved the american dream
has also written autobiography about his
journey so that you can enjoy it
and learn from it here's ron corey your
book is called tenacity and it's all
about your life from
marine strength to new york hustle to
live in the vegas life right
it is it is all about my it is my life
story in that autobiography yes
if we combine all of those moments in
your life it is
achieving the american dream achieving
the american dream in the form of the 20
businesses i've started or purchased
and i cannot give enough credit to
my success came with the help of great
business partners
i've had three significant business
partners in various ventures
uh that coupled with having three
children
uh and five grandsons motivates me
to achieve things succeed and provide
for the people i care about that's
beautiful we always have to remember to
attribute our success and our happiness
to the people around us right
it's not all about you that's right
that's right and my support people i
have to thank everyone in my life that
helped me get to where i am
what does the american dream mean to you
can you define it for us because i think
it's a little different for everybody
it is well you know health and happiness
are critical it's not
all about money while it's nice to be
financially secure
though that success comes with making
good choices in life
but that's all worthless without health
and happiness having survived cancer
and covid uh enables me to do the things
i want to do now
like pursuing a new business like
squarepanda
and as a board member i donate time for
the metro police foundation
and i like to play recreational poker at
the bellagio
in fact i was featured one month
on the cover of card player magazine the
poker bible
in this country so life today is
marketing my book playing poker and
pursuing some business challenges
but not as heavy as it was when i was
working in multiple businesses at the
same time of course you
you experienced some major corruption
you know back in the day in vegas too
so there are plenty of people trying to
stop you and get in the way
but you you persevered through all of
that
i actually encountered a corrupt city
council member
who was a competitor in private business
wow because our council members served
part-time
and he was a competitor in business and
used his power as a councilman
to try to frame me with multiple felony
charges
and that is the centerpiece of the book
in how that developed
and how i overcame it and i think people
will be intrigued
with the somewhat out of the box
thinking
and creativity that i had to employ
to clear my name and
teach him a lesson that he had coming
he's not going to
disclose what we did but it's a great
story
sounds juicy all right get your copy of
tenacity on amazon
and for more information just visit
roncoryauthor.com we'll be right back